this video was sponsored by Flo toys
[Music]
the four-beat weave is the foundation
trick for all of their interlocking
partner poi directs here from Drex
vector comm helping you bring the joy of
flow to your world and I'm here with my
friend Tashi to show you how to do the
four-beat partner weave before we dive
in I just wanted to give a quick shout
out to the friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk flow toys pirate
era light toys lmf props spin balls and
ultra poi for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all of these amazing
companies and the work that they're
doing is support flowers like yourself
by checking out the links down in the
description this video this is the first
partner trick that most people learn you
and your partner are going to weave
together with just one hand because it's
important we're going to do a quick
review of communication we'll be
counting down our entry every time by
saying here next now so we're both clear
on our timing sound good touchy sounds
great we call this trick a four beat
because each individual partner will
perform four down beats in the course of
this trick it also has a pretty gentle
learning curve I've been able to teach
it to complete strangers in less than 10
minutes
the first thing both you and your
partner will need to do is get used to
the arm movement in this trick practice
without poi to start having each partner
perform a three-beat weave with their
hand going forwards and reverse to get a
rough idea of how this will feel you're
going to want to spin your arm twice
when it is across your body and once
when it's on its native side you'll also
want to orient your body so that your
hand is going back and forth in front of
and behind you in wall plane rather than
side-to-side and wheel plane when that
feels comfortable walk through it with
your partner first let's pick whose arm
is going forward and whose arm is going
to reverse being us how I'm taller I'm
going to go forward for reasons that
we'll get into later to perform this
weave each of us will have to catch and
push the others arm between our bodies a
motion that I usually like to call
hooking or pushing backtracks and I are
very handed so we will want to learn
this trick with our right hand first we
will start facing each other and then I
will take a step to my left now if you
or your partner or both are left-handed
you can just as easily take that step to
the right instead I'll start with my
hand pointed out straight in front of me
and I'm going to swing my arm around
over hers sweeping both of our arms
between our bodies until there in front
of me and behind Tashi it's now my job
to hang out here until she comes around
to catch me I'll swing my arm around
like I'm doing a backstroke and catch
strikes these are up from underneath and
then I'll push both arms over in front
of us and leave my arm waiting for X's
arm cool and I'm going to swing my arm
down and around like I'm doing the crawl
stroke up and over to catch hers from
above basically this is your cycle
lather rinse repeat I wait for her to
push me from under she waits for me to
push her from over I wait for her to
push her from over now let's try to slip
boy the one last piece of the puzzle is
to perform one extra beat when your arm
is on its native side and you're waiting
for your partner to catch you this means
you'll get in two beats with the poi on
each side now let's try that together
I'll start by sticking my arm straight
out with the poi and I'm going to sweep
my arm and poi over top of her arm and
push both of our arms to the other side
of our bodies I'll spend a beat with my
PO well Tashi reaches around
I'll reach around like I'm doing the
backstroke and swing it and redirects
this arm then I'll push both of our arms
over to the other side I'll drop my hand
employed down and around behind me like
I'm doing the crawl stroke and reach
them both up and over top of Tasha's
hand while she hangs out and adds an
extra beat with her poi so each partner
has the same rhythm for this push your
partner's hand through hang out for a
beat let your partner push your hand
through swing back around your poi might
get tangled as you do this trick or they
might not match up very well this
happens a lot when someone speeds up or
slows down too much count the beads as
you move and it can help fix this as you
and your partner get more comfortable
doing this move you should be able to
work in tandem together and neither of
you should have to push very hard this
should feel more like a dance rather
than an arm wrestle once you get it down
neither person should feel like they're
leading so now I want to introduce you
to a variation of this move that
switches up the gameplan just a bit
currently we switch off who is doing the
pushing on each side but you can
actually make it so that the same person
is always pushing if the person during
the forward
we've is always pushing they will always
push the move below the wrists but if
you have the person doing the reverse
we've always pushing they will always
push about the wrist I'm a much bigger
fan of having the person doing the
forward we've always pushing and this
has kind of become the norm among the
people that I do partner poi with we
call it the downstream rule sometimes
the poi can look like brutal Rapids as
they spin the rabbit's go in a
downstream direction and so do the poi
in addition to making it easy to know
what your weaves are going to look like
with any partner this rule also keeps
the move at a manageable height if there
happens to be a big height difference
between you and your partner
Tashi and I are gonna be using the
downstream rule throughout this series
and we highly recommend that you do the
same it's gonna save a lot of confusion
later on make sure that each partner
practices being downstream and upstream
with each hand it's always better to
have more options it takes a little bit
more work at the wrist but you can also
do these weaves with both of you facing
in the same direction this will also
help down the road so make sure to
practice facing each way here's a 4b
from a few different angles so that you
can get a better view of it
[Music]
and now let's take those four beats and
try and string them together if you
learn this with both hands
you can switch which hand is doing the
weave wait for the moment right before
you push your partner's hand or they're
about to push yours and simply swap out
which hand is in place pretty cool right
valentine's Day is this Friday and
there's still just barely enough time to
get sets a point for you and you're
someone special head on over to flow
toys calm and use the code partner flow
to get 11 percent off two sets of POD
poi to get you started on your partner
point
thanks so much to Flo Toys for
sponsoring this series as you know
eleven it's it's like two people
uh-huh yeah you get it it's cute we want
to see you doing partner poi post
yourself doing this trick on instagram
with the hashtag directs factor point so
we can check out your work next week
we'll cover partner three beat leaves to
make sure that you see it when it drops
please make sure you hit subscribe and
hit the notification bell so you don't
miss any of the videos in this series
for set you all loose I also just want
to put out a massive thank you to all of
my wonderful supporters on patreon they
are the reason that this video and all
the videos on this channel exist if you
would like to support the work that I do
please head on over to patreon comm
slash directs factor poi and sign up
you'll get early access to all of my
content including future videos in this
series as well as a vote in what topics
I tackle in the future thank you in
advance